des années 90 et c'est vrai que c'était
une star des années 90 elle va nous
raconter tout ce qui s'est passé pour
elle et c'est vrai que c'est un truc
incroyable ce sera dans un instant pour
le moment on va revenir au dossier du
jour on va revenir sur Patrick pauvre
d'Arvor puisquil y a un nouveau
rebondissement dans cette affaire il est
visé par de nombreuses accusations de
violence sexuelle ces dernières année
lundi dernier le journaliste a été mis
en examen pour viol l'accusation est
portée par la journaliste Florence
Porcel on en a déjà parlé ici et c'est
elle qui avait été la première
d'ailleurs à se manifester pour des
faits qui dateraient de
2009 faire le point avec Augustin donadu
un journaliste chez C news donc il a
juste à traverser la rue et à venir le
temps qui traverse la r on regarde un
petit récap et il sera là j sera pr
allez c'est
[Musique]
parti il a longtemps été la star du JT
de
TF1 messieur bonsoir voici les titres de
l'actualité de ce mardi mais depuis 2021
Patrick Poivre d'Arvor est accusé par
plusieurs femmes de viol et d'agression
sexuelle j'ai repoussé d'une main son
visage et alors que journaliste journi
les accusations dont il fait l'objet
l'homme a été mise en examen hier après
une plainte de l'autrice Florence Porcel
Patrick pauvre d'Arvor mise en examen
pour un viol commis en 2009 alors
Patrick Poivre d'Arvor mise en examen
pour viol que s'est-il
passé je regarde tout je me mêle de tout
merci Augustin d'être avec nous merci
beaucoup Augustin donadieux excellent
journaliste chez C news que je regarde
très souvent merci même la nuit même la
nuit merci beaucoup des fois je mets mon
réveil pour te voir ah oui ça me fait
très plaisir garde de tout je me mêle de
tout sache-le et voilà et merci ben non
c'est ça moi qui ça fait plaisir parce
que ça fait très plaisir que tu sois là
on a Alexandra fra qui est avec nous
également qui a écrit un livre PPDA et
moi Alexandra qui était déjà venu nous
voir oui et c'est vrai que votre
histoire vous c'est c'est c'est c'est
assez fou parce Queen fait vous défendez
PPDA même si voilà vous avez eu des des
des petits soucis comme n avez dit avec
lui exactement donc vous allez nous
raconter ça dans un instant déjà
Augustin est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer ce qui est reproché à Patrick
po av d'avant dans le cadre de cette
mise en examen beaucoup de choses déjà
il faut savoir que ça se passe en deux
temps première plainte donc de Florence
porcell c'est en février 2021 elle porte
plainte contre le le journaliste star de
TF1 un présentateur de de 20h pendant de
très nombreuses années pour un viol
supposé commis en 2004 et une flation
forcé en 2009 alors je vais employer
toujours le conditionnel
puisquévidemment il y a la présomption
d'innocence à l'heure à laquelle je vous
parle il faut savoir que cette première
plainte débouchera sur un non lieu
Florence porcell réattaquera une
nouvelle fois qui et bien Patrick Poivre
d'Arvor ça se passe à l'été à l'été
pardon en novembre 2021 elle se
constitue donc partie civile et donc
cette plainte débouche aujourd'hui sur
et bien une mise en examen de Patrick
Poivre d'Arvor contre les réquisitions
du parquet c'est ça qui c'est ça qui dit
et c'est sur ça qu'il faut aussi
insister c'est-à-dire que les juges
d'instruction n'ont pas suivi les
réquisitions du parquet c'est assez
inédit c'est c'est fou pourquoi G bah
parce que les deux magistrates ont jugé
qu'il y avait assez d'éléments pour le
mettre en examen c'est vrai que c'est un
rebondissement inattendu il est mis en
examen pour une affaire et témoins
insisté pour un second fait et ce qui
est très intéressant c'est que pour
certains de ces faits il pourrait y
avoir prescription mais les magistrat
ont estimé qu'il était possible qu'il y
ait un caractère sériel dans toute cette
affaire c'est-à-dire caractère sériel ça
veut dire même mode opératoire des
victimes qui se ressemblent un peu et un
seul auteur c'est pour ça qu'elle
pourrait aussi décider de réinterroger
d'autres plaignantes en disant s'il y a
un modus opérandi ça s'appelle comme ça
sur le plan judiciaire peut-être que on
peut entendre d'autres gens et peut-être
qu'on pourrait lui reprocher d'autres
faits voilà oui Augustin et la question
qui peut se poser j'ai appelé deux
avocats pénaliste pour avoir la réponse
même eux ne l'avaient pas c'est que si
jamais le caractère sériel comme vous
dites Gilles est est reconnu est-ce que
la prescription des faits supposés en
2004 en 1990 et cetera cette
prescription pourrait-elle être levée au
quel cas le dossier pourrait s'alourdir
contre Patrick pvre d'Arvor 40 femmes
l'accuse 22 femmes ont été entendues et
ce matin chez l'une de nos confrères
apuline de Malerbe une plaignante a cité
d'autres chiffres 49 femmes sont allées
voir la police il y aurait eu 24
plaintes 12 pour viol dont un viol de
mineur c'est bien CZ même ceux qui sont
derrière vous dans l'Info maintenant
puceque vous êtes numéro 1 maintenant
c'est news 1 c'est bien c'est beau c'est
fairplay et on salue le travail de la
rédaction et direction qui est
fantastique de c'est news bien sûr vous
bah oui vous première chaîne maintenant
à faut ouais c'est bien de citer les
deuxièm c'est ce que je fais
toujours Alexandra merci d'être avec
nous est-ce que vous pouvez nous
raconter votre rencontre avec ppéia vous
l'aviez déjà fait mais c'est vrai que
parce que vous avez fait publier un
livre PPDA et moi oui et sur la
couverture il y a justement le carton
PPDA le fameux con c'est ça qui est fou
parce qu'il y a sa carte de visite sur
la la la couve et chè Alexandra merci
beaucoup pour votre envoi les mots que
vous aviez employés me vont droite au
cœur venez me voir un soir pour le JT
nous parlerons ensuite bien fidèlement
ça faisait partie effectivement de son
mode opératoire ses cartons qui était
connu de tous à l'époque pu qu'on
parlait des cartons c'est vous AZ mis en
cou oui oui j'ai j'ai gardé j'ai eu la
chance de garder ce carton qui est
vraiment représentatif un peu de sa
façon d'opérer c'est vrai vous racontez
vous racontez vre histoire vous vous
vous avez dénoncé avoir été agressé
trois fois par le journaliste en fait je
l'ai connu en 2005 effectivement la tour
TF1 et là il y a eu pas mal de rebond
isement déjà en 2005 dans l'escalier de
secours de la tour TF1 et puis après il
y a eu d'autres événements chez lui à
Neï que je relate dans ce livre en
2010 en 2017 et aussi je parle de tous
les événements littéraires où je les
croisé au fil des ans puisque ça couvre
une période de près de 20 ans où j'ai
été témoin de ses agissements de son
mode opératoire témoin de l'époque aussi
qui le soutenait qui Val IDIS ses
comportements et en fait je notais tout
dans des cahiers en détail tous les
dialogues donc j'ai tout raconté dans
les moindres détails pour vraiment
montrer sa psychologie mais pas que la
sienne la psychologie aussi de
l'environnement parce que il y avait
tout un milieu qui
finalement considérait que son ses
agissements étaient normaux légitimes et
que c'était normal de faire venir des
filles dans dans les bureaux que c'était
normal que les filles jouent le jeu pour
la promotion de leur livres et cetera
donc tout ça est est retracé dans le
détail et ça fait partie d'une époque
qui je pense est rejeté en ce moment et
lui il fait figure un peu de ce rejet il
incarne ce rejet de tout cette époque
quoi juste brièvement est-ce que vous
pouvez nous raconter votre première
rencontre c'était quoi c'était pour
alors justement j'ai je suis tombée sur
son livre je lui ai écrit et
immédiatement j'ai eu à la fois le
carton doublé d'un appel de Marie-Hélène
sa secrétaire pour m'inviter au JT je
suis pas allée au JT mais il a tout de
suite il s'est rendu disponible
l'après-midi très longuement et il a
écouté il a il m'a prêté beaucoup
d'attention ça a duré très longtemps ça
fait partie aussi de son mode opératoire
effectivement il y a un certain nombre
de choses qui reviennent ce fait
d'instaurer une relation de supériorité
avec les personnes des personnes jeunes
en général un peu en quête de
reconnaissance en quête d'identité en
quête d'une place et de d'éditeurs
souvent donc ça ça revient beaucoup dans
le livre et je pense qu'il y a un profil
effectivement alors euh après vous êtes
allé chez lui que vous dites je suis
allé chez lui je l'ai revu à des
événements littéraires forcément il est
un peu incontournable il était
incontournable en tout cas dans le monde
littéraire c'était un peu un passage
obligé comme moi et donc je l'ai
recroisé il m'a effectivement se voilà
comme comme non mais c'est moi aussi je
suis incontournable dans le monde
littéraire dans le monde de la
télé dans le monde de la télé a pas un
livre qui sort sans que je donne mon
aval s'est refusé de mourir exactement
bravo bravo Franch ça me fait plaisir ça
ça me fait plaisir mais c'est vrai que
c'est Al savez qui a dit ça en plus que
je croyais que c'était moi bah c'est pas
moi c'est pas vrai je vous jure que
c'est vrai bah j'ai vu ça la dernière
fois en fait c'est pas moi c'est qui
c'est un vrai gars je vous jure je crois
je me demande je me demande si c'est pas
M passon qui a dit lire c'est refusé de
mourir et en fait moi je croyais que
c'était moi et Masson m'a copié
bâtard gu 2 guide 2 m'a copié scandaleux
c'est vrai c'est fou vérifiez vous avez
rien à faire euh non pas vous augustinen
vous travailleez je parle des
autres Alexandra la question que tout le
monde se pose c'est pourquoi vous vous
le soutenez aujourd'hui je soutiens
parce que dans mon livre je montre aussi
mon ambiguïé parce que je revenais je le
voir c'est le cas d'autres femmes aussi
je suis même allée chez lui c'est quand
même un peu fort de se mettre dans la
gueule du loup comme ça et je pense
qu'on peut pas nier aussi le rôle que
les femme joue et que moi j'ai joué en
tout cas à partir de mon témoignage et
je parle aussi de l'époque qui a joué un
rôle qui a soutenu son comportement
enfin qui en tout cas validé c'est
intéressant ce que vous dites parce que
il y a plein de gens euh qui qui qui
vont vous dire oui mais vous étiez
peut-être sous emprise et cetera donc
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à ça parce
que c'est vrai les gens vous dire oui
vous êtes allé une deuxième fois une
troisème fois parce que c'est c'est un
peu c'est un peu ce qui s'est passé pour
les les les les autres victimes
également présumé exactement elles
reviennent souvent c'est ça mais vous
vous vous y alliez quoi qu'est-ce qu'
vous aviez il y avait une fascination
pour le personnage c'est qu'il y avait
deux facettes une facette très sombre et
une facette derrière des apparences
nobles effectivement quand on est quand
on est très jeune on est fasciné par ce
double ce côté double et d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça que j'illustre ça un peu
en exerc par Jackie land Hyde parce que
c'est de Stevenson voilà Mr H mais vous
savez que c'est c'est fascinant quand on
vous écoute parce que du coup moi j'ai
rencontré beaucoup de fois Patrick pre
d'Arvor dans le cadre de mes promos et
tout ça il avait d'ailleurs une sorte de
petit drague insistante à mon encontre
ah ouais mais quand je vous écoute en
fait je vois Patrick pvre ARV vous avez
sa diction son phrasé sa gestuel c'est
un compliment ben je sais pas si c'est
un compliment mais je trouve que c'est
étrange en fait de vous voir parce que
j'ai l'impression vraiment fou ce que
vous dit que vous avez une telle B
peut-être tendresse
fascination voilà ou je sais pas mais je
vous assure c'est je vous regarde depuis
tout à l'heure et c'est très troublant
votre façon de parler de regarder vous y
a même une sorte de mimétisme je vous
assure pourtant je dénonce ses
comportements dans mon livre c'est pas
du tout une apologie de Poivre d'Arvor
raconte tout dans les détails aussi son
mode opératoire et la façon dont il
cible des jeunes femmes en général en
marche vulnérabl qui sont en quête
d'identité qui sont en construction et
aussi avec un focus sur l'anorexie un
focus sur les jeunes femmes en recherche
d'éditeurs et ça c'est pas bien et je le
dis et je suis pas là pour le défendre
je suis là pour établir la nuance et
l'équilibre aussi parce qu'il y a quand
même un juste milieu à trouver dans tous
ces débats aujourd'hui relation
homme-femme parce qu'on est on est parti
vers des extrêmes VE oui mais je trouve
qu'il y a quelque chose de très
paradoxal dans V témoignage parce que
d'un côté vous reconnaissez qu'il y a eu
des agressions des agissements déplacés
et de l'autre vous lui trouvez comme des
circonstanceces atteignante en disant
oui mais l'époque permettez deux et
cetera et je pense que dans les années
2000 peut-être qu'on pouvait se
comporter de manière différente mais un
viol reste un viol je pense qu'un viol
c'était pas ok même dans les années 2000
Ann c'est recontextualiser en fait
est-ce que vous n'avez pas peur que
votre témoignage décrédibilise ceux
d'autres femmes qui portent plainte et
qui elle ont le sentiment réellement
d'avoir été agressé sexuellement et vous
remettez un espèce de contexte on dit
oui mais à l'époque c'était peut-être ok
de se faire agresser sexuellement non
parce que je suis pour la libération de
la parole je trouve que mon témoignage
contribue justement à dénoncer l'époque
et aussi l'environnement qui permettait
ses agissements parce qu'il y a pas que
lui c'est facile de le désigner lui en
tant que monstre en tant que voilà
personne qui supporte toute la
responsabilité mais il y avait aussi
l'environnement euh excusez-moi
Alexandra est-ce que vous pouvez juste n
nous raconter parce qu'il y a un moment
très fort dans le livre c'est ront vous
raconter dans dans dans dans le dans
dans l'escalier de service de de TF1
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé en fait il
s'est jeté sur moi mais prof vous avez
pris l'escalier de service en fait en
fait il m'a dit de le suivre et moi je
l'ai suivi il avait quand même une
certaine
autorité voilà on était un peu intimidé
donc je l'ai suivi il m'a dit suivez-moi
et donc je l'ai suivi je pensais qu'on
allait dîner ah oui
oui et puis après je me suis retrouvé
dans l'escalier de secours et là il
s'est arrêté il s'est il m'a embrassé il
s'est jeté sur moi il s allé plus loin
et puis je lui ai dit non ça c'est aussi
une des raisons pour lesquelles je le
défends c'est j'ai dit dit allit plus
loin ici c'est pas il a mis la main dans
mon jeans voilà et la raison aussi pour
la je je lu ai dit non explicitement
effectivement j'ai j'ai il a il s'est
arrêté il y a toute cette question
aujourd'hui de la sidération
effectivement qui était pas présente à
l'époque on parlait pas du tout de ça
mais je pense que c'est important
aujourd'hui mais ça l'était pas à
l'époque et c'était pas quelque chose
dont la loi c'est quelque chose qui a
pas intégré la loi encore alors est-ce
que si on vous demande vous seriez prête
à témoigner si on vous le demandz ou pas
du tout oui je serais prête à témoigner
oui dans une quête de vérité je pense
que c'est important c'est aussi le but
de mon livre c'est dresser un portrait
de l'époque à partir de mon témoignage
bien sûr je suis pas en train de dire
que mon témoignage mais je l'ai quand
même connu sur de nombreuses années j'ai
fréquenté les événements littéraires
j'ai vu à quel point il était adulé et
comment se comportaient les personnes
autour de lui les
éditeurs les les auteurs voilà les
romancières enfin toutes ces jeunes
femmes aussi Augustin il risque quoi
patriavant alors il peut y y avoir un
non Liu là aussi il peut être déféré
devant un tribunal pour être jugé mais
évidemment cela c'est on va dire à long
terme c'est dans un an et demi 2 ans ou
même plus hein si si le juge en décide
autrement et ce qu'il risque c'est 15
ans de de réclusion puisque là on parle
de d'un crime un viol c'est un crime
donc 15 ans de réclusion criminelle 20
ans s'il y a des circonstances
aggravantes et là il y a tout un tout un
détail voilà si la personne est sous
emprise de stupéfiant et cetera même
sous emprise psychologique aussi c'est
une circonstance s agravante alors on en
est pas là pour le moment puisque
l'enquête suit son cours des auditions
vont avoir lieu mais voilà ce qui risque
patrick Poivre d'avir merci Alexandra
fra ou dans dans mon livre d'ailleurs il
y a un chapitre sur Florence Porcel
parce que j'ai rencontré longuement sa
meilleure amie de l'époque Martine avec
qui elle a échangé de nombreux messages
en 2009 aussi la période de la du viol
supposé merci en tout cas merci d'avoir
été avec nous alexandrara et merci vous
a exellouver bien s sur C new prière cha
d'info merci merci